الصحفي
ومتحدث العسكري باسم انصار الله الحوثيين
وان الله على نصرهم لقدير صدق الله العظيم
انتصارا لمظلوم الشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه الذي يتعرض حتى هذه اللحظه لابشع
انواع المجازر من قبل الكيان الصهيوني وفي
اطار الرد على العدوان الامريكي
البريطانيه على بلدنا نفذت القوات البحريه
في القوات المسلحه بعون الله تعالى عمليه
عسكريه استهدفت سفينه امريكيه في خليج عدن
وذلك بعدد من الصواريخ البحريه المناسبه
وكانت الاصابه دقيقه ومباشره ان القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه تعتبر كافه السفن وال
والقطع الحربيه الامريكيه
والبريطانيه المشاركه في العدوان على
بلدنا اهدافا معاديه ضمن بنك اهداف قواتنا
ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه تؤكد ان الرد
على الاعتداءات الامريكيه والبريطانيه
قادم لا محاله وان اي اعتداء جديد لن يبقى
دون رد وعقاب ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه
مستمره في تنفيذ عملياتها العسكريه وفرض
قرار منع الملاحه الاسرائيليه في البحرين
العربي والاحمر حتى وقف العدو
ورفع الحصار عن الشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه تؤكد
استمرار حركه التجاره في البحرين العربي
والاحمر الى كافه الوجهات عدا موانئ
فلسطين المحتله وانها مستمره في اتخاذ
كافه الاجراءات الدفاعيه
والهجوميه ضمن حق الدفاع والتصدي للعدوان
الامريكي البريطاني والله حسبنا ونعم
الوكيل نعم المولى ونعم النصير عاش اليمن
حرا عزيزا مستقلا والنصر لليمن ولكل احرار
الامه صنعاء الرابع من رجب
1445 للهجره الموافق للخ عشر من يناير
2024 صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه